Perry and Megan and the royalty that's
piping hot and boiling over look it
seems like there's no road back for
William and Harry now among the big
Royal Bombshells Harry revealing just
how heated things got when he faced the
firing squad of the firm
this seems to be an attempt to take down
the royal family it was terrifying to
have my brother scream and shouts at me
and my grandmother you know quietly sit
there and sort of take it all in this
meeting happened five days after the
couple announced that they would be
standing down as Royals the queen
understandably wanted the situation
resolve we don't know exactly what was
shouted William does have a temper
William can be quite stubborn I was
given five options
one being all in no change five being
all out
I chose option three in the meeting
half in half out one person who did not
attend Megan Harry claims that was no
coincidence there was only once maggot
left and gone back to Canada
that it was then arranged it was clear
to me that they planned it so that you
weren't in the room
that same day a report surfaced claiming
William quote bullied Harry inside the
summit the power swiftly released a
joint statement from the brothers
calling the story quote false offensive
and potentially harmful but Harry says
there's just one problem no one will ask
me permission to put my name to a
statement like that within four hours
they were happy to lie
to protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
Harry claims the Tabloid war on Megan
caused so much stress it could have
triggered her miscarriage in July of
2020. I can say from what I saw
that miscarriage was created by what
they were trying to do to her you are
making people want to kill me
you are making me scared and in the
midst of this Sussex storm of Bombshells
The Prince and Princess of Wales
publicly keep calm and carry on the two
were all smiles in London arriving at
the together at Christmas Carol service
with Prince George and Princess
Charlotte today's docu-series has
clashed with a concert at Westminster
Abbey being hosted by the Princess of
Wales they haven't commented what
they're going to do is continue working
and showing a sense of unity in the dark
we see William did reach out to Harry
the morning after their Oprah interview
wow the NBA just got to talk to his
brother one can only imagine that it was
not a friendly text we know that William
was apoplectic over the allegations of
racism and Megan got a text from music
royalty queen bee fiance just texted
it we flawless
[Music]